historically it's been involved for a
very long time it also is a major
supporter of key Arab governments and
Israel it is not as if the United States
has no role in the arab-israeli issue
and all of a sudden getting involved in
mediation is a major step the United
States provides military support to
Israel financial supporters it also
provides military support and financial
support to Jordan to Egypt to
Palestinian government to other Arab
governments so the United States is part
of the picture the only question is does
the United States use this participation
to also get the protagonists together
now there are benefits or the United
States because in terms of the
perception in the Muslim world the
Palestinian issue matters for whatever
reason after close you know six years it
has become the signature issue in
American relations with the Middle East
and the Muslim world it is a corrosive
issue I don't think a piece with the
prez elution will change larger issues
in the Middle East such as Iran's power
such as us as other interests in the
region but it will have enormous amount
of symbolic value let it let's put it
this way not trying at all was quite
detrimental to American image much more
so than trying and failing